oh my God look who's outside yet I get
in it Colin Quinn is wandering around
outside like he's like a homeless person
yeah I'd like to get his take on all
this good morning all right show
businesses Colin Quinn is here
show biz show businesses Colin Quinn sit
down you just woke up hey you just woke
up Jesus it's not that nice no sorry no
so you look like you should challenge
the day and defeated welcome Colin cool
just talking about the Golden Globes we
were in the afterglow of the Golden
Globes we loved awards season here on
the show it's very inclusive this year
Oh God you loved that Jim what what
about what a crushing bore it is yeah it
really is I mean that monologue I loved
I loved hearing that monologue because I
was that good that's what you want
is that what you wanted to show business
good that's humour now just all the
finding to make fun of not you know but
saying hey we're gonna be edgy well
we're not really of course you're not
right we're making fun of the idea of
being edgy yes right act like because
that's what we should be doing can you
imagine if we insulted you guys let's
make fun of that all gone so indicative
of what's going on yeah really it's
never gonna change them comedy everyone
has been saying it's gonna swing back
and we've been talking about if it's not
yeah never gonna swing back not in our
lifetime but uh maybe like if there was
a real what we need you know is that
natural disaster would really bring back
things that I let him brought it back
for a little while but then all of a
sudden that then it went back again well
no but I mean much bigger than that I
mean like a natural like a you know like
a tsunami level thing where suddenly
everyone is like oh you know I have to
eat I have to you know survive and then
yeah the humor comes back from that from
the primal sources no maybe that's
because what is it because people don't
let's hope people don't worry so much
about Rob's got to get by you to adjust
the cameras just to make sure that your
frames properly come
[Laughter]
yeah so you think that if there's a
natural disaster what people's
sensitivities kind of relax a little bit
we realize that maybe all this all this
other stuff isn't quite as important as
we make it out I don't know what else
that's just a shot in the dark for what
could happen at like Jim said it
certainly doesn't seem like he's going
back I used to sell everybody's going
back I had that conversation with every
comedian to look you know it's gonna go
I think no it's not probably that it's
unfortunate yeah I'm not swinging back I
mean it hasn't you would think it would
have swung back already because we
thought we'd gone as far as we were
gonna go the comedians are getting
involved with it now the comedians are
getting outraged 12:00 - yeah yeah good
yeah yeah well you would think you would
think like we were talking about when
you've got you are we already had it
like we had Ricky Gervais by hosting the
same award show right where he was
making fun of the celebrities wasn't
even wasn't brutal he was just he was
just doing this funny he was funny but
that was looked at like that's what was
being made fun of last thing full
disclosure Ricky Gervais says folks has
also been a serious employee trouble
when people start to notice rightfully
nothing of interest that right Roland it
reminds me of uh Orson Welles in the
Citizen Kane he's pulling the strings
he's the puppet master years one day
that that snow globe will just fall
finally you'll realize it wasn't worth
it Roland it wasn't worth it but that's
what was being made fun of the idea that
can you get the idea of mockery right
somebody would go on can you believe
that somebody would make fun of Mel
Gibson to his face all of the audacity
of it all yeah did you want we were just
playing the clip of Sandra Oh's serious
moment after they had had all right and
somebody it was so over the top that
even in the audience somebody didn't
realize that she was trying to have a
moment and laughed at her open I know I
was impressed by the acting part the
same thing I said oh she's being ironic
right he can't he can't switch in the
middle of some medicine
just wait a segment is oh yeah I should
have hosted yeah that was that was the
opening for never mind yeah
what for Anthony to do guys
no that's why gestured to him but it
wasn't he was always there well that's
Tecna and same we're in on the joke I
didn't get it it was a radio thing the
audience doesn't know the radio thing no
but I didn't get it cuz I know I seat
you man all right
right Jim's like no but it's the wrong
seat well no you just didn't get it is I
come on we're both right yeah you're
right you're right of course
oh yeah what about uh meanwhile not to
take thee now the what used to be called
the gay angle but I'd like to say I am a
little angry the Stars no one didn't
mean no I didn't see you sorry sir I saw
what I did see I heard had a lovely
score actually did and I have to say mr.
Jim is a little biased he is a little
monsters there now that should
innominate first of all dice was fine it
was it was like oh my god it was a baby
was good but then I wasn't doing dirty
limericks though so all of a sudden
people go like I can't believe he can
speak like a human exactly the standards
may have been a little over dice man
right and then and then but it was cool
it was right one movies I'm watching it
and I'm uh I was like I don't want to
see this movies to law I hate it I hate
of the original stars of bones both of
them was that Kris Kristofferson and
that's it was boring and then Barbara's
rising this was good this is better
great yell did I heard good things
that's it did you watch the Queen movie
that one the Bohemian I was in first 15
minutes and it was like he's they put a
love story the whole thing first of all
together directed as I go serial child
molester directed by Brian saying I was
like that the same Brian singer by the
way I don't know if you stayed up for
the whole thing last night no mention of
Brian singer in the acceptance oh of
course
no no no no he wasn't on stage no
mention of like it was thanks to Freddie
Mercury thanks to the wonderful
producers thanks to the two stars of the
30
fainted director no-one's ever not
thanked the director now there's no way
they're gonna thank him after they
should have had like just a footage of
like what's-his-name with with with Burt
Reynolds in Boogie Nights when he's
behind the saloon Jack just so innocent
the size small Jack I never touched them
I never touched me just look at them
they're so small we're friends right
yeah there it is
I'm here bats do you guess but yeah so
you are selling the 15 minutes what's 50
minutes per day I already said it's like
this weird movie is not good right
honest horrible even when they opened
just to have a great song like all up
front like bad like whatever I figured
but I was loose it was the one of the
best songs of Queen right up front
during their approved no reason I was
like this movie's gonna stink right they
spent and that's the thing like they
trick people you see movies do this
sometimes they trick people into
thinking it's a good movie because the
music is so good so they're playing
these Queen songs and all these people
are going oh [ __ ] I haven't heard that
song in forever yeah this song is
brilliant so this movie I guess is
brilliant you go no no no no no yes
you're just enjoying the song they
destroyed Freddie Mercury's legacy in
the movie I think we can safely say that
we can first of all yeah did you know
he's gay I didn't know that no I when I
was going up we never you know we people
say Queen the gate will I go shut up
nobody knows England what are you
talking about yeah that's a that's so
weird to me that you would watch that in
there was a generation that was with
Queen that was sitting there going like
there's no this is manly a man as can be
we didn't know Rob Halford was gay like
right you look back at all the old but
Judas Priest videos where he's like
wearing leather and it's you know
hell-bent for leather and all this like
you know it's it's like you had a little
gay leather hats and like how did
everybody not know we had no idea was
gay we just thought what a badass
leather man right no that's probably the
steel dragon scene was based on right
right right when he goes oh yes that's
right oh right yes yo it's the greatest
when he when he goes like he goes like
well you know Elvis used to do this and
then one of the band mates goes yeah but
he was the King and then he goes and
what does that make me the Queen yeah
very funny and he leaves the band that's
the that's rock star well Mark Wahlberg
has to replace him one
the most underrated great movies of all
- dude it's my favorite movie of all and
honestly it's better than Bohemian
Rhapsody yeah no it's a good
I watched it ironically that sounds like
a you know you don't admit to people you
like it but I've actually liked it
underneath rock star rock star my wife I
want something more than twice without
kind of liking it right
my wife is disgusted by mix I'll put it
on I'll start doing the lines as they're
doing it like I know the entire movie
front to back she's gonna poison you
exactly say you think you see you know
whatever you being it's not cute now
they hate him stinks but it was hot yeah
she was whoo and so was the other one
Jennifer Aniston yeah right who ends up
being low with somebody of Jim's taste
who does there's this the the you
talking about the assistant right the
assistant in the movie that's like
flirting with her eyes and has an orgy
with with Mark Wahlberg and Jennifer
Aniston but then after all the sex has
happened Mark Wahlberg realizes that in
rock and roll not everything is as it
appears to be because she's pissing
standing up in the morning oh and you go
oh man get that whole course she's
pissing standing up I gotta watch it
again
you got to there's a lot of little
details you got about a good girl and
you know was in it what's his face you
know from the affair he's in everything
oh yeah yeah yeah
what's a Dominic West yeah from the wire
yeah yeah he's Kirk Cuddy yeah you say
he's one of the leads you know like this
movie I'll watch it it's great it's a
new right yes in 1999 there's so much
about it like I think yeah 1999 2000
first close one 2001 it was the peak
time that nobody cared about hair metal
anymore no that's right so why it would
take place then who knows the cast is
phenomenal like it's a whole bunch of a
listers and this movie that you're like
what the how the hell did this even get
made yeah everything about it is amazing
that's right right exactly how exact
wilder than that alright I know that
yeah he's just for him he's in the band
I've got like two lines he's got the
shotgun out the window that he's like
you know he's shooting road signs with
it is the tour bus is going through
because Timothy roll is wild yeah let me
just say let me go back for one second
the Golden Globes do you think there's
anybody who's not like severely mentally
damaged who
watch that last night instead of
laughing and going this was
entertainment and this was a good time
people who blog about stuff like that
who with it where they hear the word
inclusion they're happy like people who
think like that enjoyed it
there are cues right could you enjoy it
or they were just enjoying the idea of
it probably sound could you enjoy the
actual experience of such a boring
I think it's free idea I think there are
little cues like there are cue words
that when they're said or when a famous
person laughs or whatever you go that's
funny that's good because Andy Samberg
is making the audience laugh do we have
any of it the opening monologue
inclusion I'm sure it's out there I
don't have anything on my board or a lot
well it's a long story
we'd have to yeah we'd have to you have
to del Del T there we go we don't get
the opening monologue from other I'll
bet we have it check the email that was
sent oh yes what maybe yeah
there was a perfect yes my man Troy was
about to find a control no yahuwah's
what is it tough Colin was it are you
starting to see the underbelly of this
system it's the same thing that happens
when you do Stern right me underbelly
Stern just kind of stammers around until
somebody comes in and find something on
YouTube go ahead Troy
[Applause]
- already bombing they dress that one
so we're there were a couple of great
that's they addressing queue they don't
have a host yet right right but that
funny stuff do they're gonna bring up
the homophobia or the you know yeah it's
edgy you know happy I am a Kevin Hart
said not a toy I walked waving it you
there are a couple moments in this thing
though where even in that room the jokes
died like there were a couple of jokes
that just got go ahead what's his name
Borat Winnie's be himself yeah I thought
you're gonna do something outrageous
would show you sitting there happy yeah
yeah I'm a regular guy shut up character
show up in like garter belts or size
like that do something crazy Hollywood
half marathon because it messes up all
the traffic you know oh yeah I hate that
race of people it's the worst race of
people now we know you guys are stand-up
comedians right you touch I'm enjoying
I'm enjoying like that yes what do you
do good stuff what do you what do you do
as a comic performer when there's a joke
like that written for you on a
teleprompter right and there you have to
repeat the punchline several times but
the first time it died like gay people
were like oh it's stupid and then you
realize race of people you're gonna have
to repeat even though nobody thought it
was funny the first time we don't have
to worry about that mm-hmm because we
are never going to be in this situation
with this teleprompters I disagree I
still hold out hope you mean like a
televised thing exactly I worry about
chicken wings and it's a roasted yeah is
the waitress gonna spill something on
someone
Samberg and Sandra oh the two nicest
people in showbiz this thing's gonna be
a snooze but not so fast because you
fools are all about to get roasted your
bass style it's already they mentioned
your babies in a way rap jokes over
yeah you know they're gonna do well
you're getting a rose if the first joke
aside all right wrap it
gervase style yeah well I'll tell you
does the right thing you as a director
lifetime fan can't wait to see what you
do next BAM face house I can't watch any
more
why is funny it's good stuff it is fun
huh see I'm so glad good it's terrible
Jim is walking in cold it's hot even see
this is good so with that I was first of
all I've been feeling well so I went to
bed probably nine o'clock less Philly no
I haven't been feeling well oh I was sad
you sure took the day off
didn't called me hey you want a
substitute host I've sat in a couple of
times been the second Mike this is
really good yeah this is good because
Jim okay we're watching it again yeah
we're gonna get your fresh take on us
you don't want any of this no god it's
okay good because he thought you might
otherwise she's gonna come from his
stomach you think you're sick before you
came in here with us you thought they
were gonna really yeah and Spike Lee
this is nice and they went the other
direction after the race through
misdirection yeah you like that
my divorce they've had them drop it they
even had him dress up in a foolish
purple suit with a purple parade to set
him up yeah you think you looked a
little silly
[Laughter]
[Music]
Bradley Cooper that's cute
you like that I do it's like he's being
roasted because he's hot it's like it's
watching really the end of comedy this
is that's cute this is what they want
I'm glad this is what the good are you
thinking about maybe shaping your act a
little bit like right this is funny yeah
that's weird
Gina Rodriguez is here yeah why is that
weird Sandra last time I checked she
resided in heaven I love that that's
cute so what they've earned what they
deserve
yeah this is earned this this is they go
back in here to slam each other I like
that you like that I do just it is more
there's more commentary why don't I go
back in here slap each other you're
worried more than I know that's funny
it's an eight-minute mile but I was
shocked at a standing but the hard
monologue is that you're worried this is
gonna last forever Colin yes it's
already - you're in purgatory
don't worry oh okay Oh Sandra oh snap
Andy Samberg more like any slams nerds
ooh I love that what else who else oh I
got one Michael B Jordan yeah
Oh more like Michael be buff AF you a
snack Michael your character's name and
Creed is Adonis and it is AB oh oh yes
get up go to him crying off that I want
to get the meme no you don't like that
one is Russian I didn't I Unite's
it's it's the idea of slamming like look
will be ironic and slam mean comedy like
look at weekend like we're making the
act like they're making fun of being
mean yeah I guess that's right yeah but
they're not no they're just being nice
because it's it's cute
that's it yeah because they can't be
funny the other way and that's you're
right it almost starts us like we're
gonna we're gonna defend against it
nobody wants to see that mean comedy
anymore right we're here's what we've
got then you go this isn't what I mean
but they had what I'm saying is there's
no other option they had right that's
why our culture is there's no option
that was a fun joke Dodie just about
that Michael Jordan BJ did you hear him
calmest you say you a snack yeah yeah I
didn't like that no buffet yeah that one
that stands for as [ __ ] I know oh you do
okay it's me they understand the
Internet exactly they're talking to the
Instagram crowd I want to see Amy Adams
get burned you like because yeah one of
my favorite I want to see you get burned
quite literally do you mean the roast
fashion no do you mean trapped by a
seatbelt of an overturned car oh no the
door won't open and the hoods on fire I
want to see your eggs get burned this
morning and have you [ __ ] throw a
hissy fit very hungry go for it try wait
who's going to get [ __ ] babies next
[ __ ] atm I wanted I'm talking about
hammy hands now you got me thinking
about food you want to get some food
cause I got it brings it up because and
see you now you got me thinking about
Colin I got some bad news
what the [ __ ] loaf already left to get
the food what without even is [ __ ]
without insulting
his phone number do you want it I'm even
worried sometimes about just the way Jim
acts about his goddamn eggs these guys
probably spits it on food oh now here he
comes up the hall right now he's
literate he's already gotten the food
Colin we can just go back for you he's
coming in if I was 25 I swear to god I'd
pick him up and dump him right now he's
not asking you didn't even consult
where's your breakfast to bodyslam him
I'm sick of bringing my own TV the
occasion out of this kids a wrestle from
Nutley he does have an Utley wrestling
oh thank you he's a [ __ ] wrestle back
in the day you know [ __ ] love and he's
still in good shape there are some of
the guests that may be a little hungry
and weren't ass I was gonna say I was
gonna say now don't bother then I
realized he [ __ ] brought me in before
he left and he didn't ask you can't you
knew Colin was here first thing he
brought me down here what's that but I
didn't know you owe anything that's a
very general question I need plenty yeah
I mean is it he says he puts the
headphones on but he still stays 30 feet
away from the microphone but yeah I
guarantee he looks just like the kind of
kid he probably spit in your eggs cuz
your shitty attitude I don't want it to
happen me so I'm gonna put on the
Charmin this is like the gold colin is
like the golden globes of breakfast
manners yeah but I can't result I'd like
to get first of all I don't want the
show to pay you know I good what is it
egg whites it tastes like the thing they
grill it on where'd you go sounds good
to me that you getting another place
downstairs in the courtyard the
expensive place what's up with that you
all right
Metro yeah yes here's a cutting corners
oh that's the expensive place that's the
place where they yeah I'm paying for my
whoa breakfast for the crew on Colin
Quinn crew
yeah all right give him a credit card
haven't ordered all around all right
yeah take orders around Troy whatever
you want it whatever anybody wants yeah
you going to the metro these are these
taste like the thing they were cooked on
Oh Jim a little why don't we do the
Metro anymore yeah
likes your scratch Jim is our little
extra scratch couple extra bucks Jimmy
couple extra bucks is that we don't go
there yeah I don't know what you got in
your contract but it's a couple of extra
I'm paying for it well I pay phone well
then you're giving what you pay for
because it's a couple extra bucks to go
down yeah go down to cafe Metro or
whatever the place is called okay these
are not good okay so what I'm buying
what do you what do you want somebody
eating them what do you want Jim stop
eating don't engine Collins gonna get
you some better food spit that out
uncle Collins gonna get you better food
he's got cheese something it out I'm
buying dinner he's buying dinner for
every day after all I'm getting some
others do I get to promote my new show
when I'm here hey that's true
stop eating it's gross even I'm
disgusted by his eggs now that I think
about the grill Jim do you want
different eggs I just save the most it
might need it okay hopefully Metro
doesn't serve most of it in the 70s I
love mustard um I don't think about
mustard I think about Jim loves it in
every meal how annoying that is to me
you don't like mustard I don't like most
and I hate that you like mustard hey you
both I've always hated mustard but now
every time think of must I think it Jim
shoveling mustard understand I love
mustard
you hate mustard you hate Jim Norton so
when those things are gonna come on you
know when I came in to the cellar and
you tried to spoil my pretzel treat oh
yeah
what did you do Colin I salt it up as
mustard and improved the mustard yeah
they put lime stuff in a this is
delicious reminded know I was great
meanwhile he spit in my goddamn team
once and I drank his I got my spit no I
had a piece of um spearmint gum oh you
put your chewed up gum and many many
years ago gum and I drink my tea I like
mint tea what day were you laughing up
gum Jim were you laughing when he said I
don't like mint tea I was I've never
been happier it's a moment that's right
Pete that's my 15 years ago yeah
and you look in the company just try and
shoot up come and I bottom I peaked
about a week later on tough crackers
tough grouse on 11th Avenue so you
couldn't get up there and Jimmy had his
kappa cheese stall box under stage there
was no stores within three blocks
mornings dogs hadn't even drank it yet
he said something snotty and I put my
breakfast treat into him this company
knew there was no way around it this is
like standing there suffering it's great
they've been amazing that those little
things those are the memories that last
forever it's like 15 years later you
click remember that time I put a coin
I can't believe is that many years ago
yeah 15 years yeah [ __ ] how old were you
15 years ago Connor what do you want
[ __ ] love to pick you up
um whatever you want it's on you I want
what are you getting at the same thing
I'll get the eggs with yeah we're kind
of exited yet hey actually being a
regular scrambled eggs
yeah buddy it's a Monday party day I
haven't eaten much this weekend so I
wasn't feeling well no I want egg whites
because I might had a heart attack I'm
supposed to eat egg whites all right now
is that bad for your heart to have
regular like sometimes no once in a
while it's fine you know what I've found
moderation cats like really eight is the
key you know you guys are so wise I want
a a tee a plane let me write it down I'm
smart yeah this is not good radio what's
giving our breakfast orders well that's
okay no we can't be having to the last
stopped you before
oh yeah we can be having some laughs oh
that's true
that's true okay Colin you're gonna
write down your order we'll get back to
the monologue the comedy monologue from
last night's Golden Globe Awards
and we can't forget Amy Adams fill your
shoes tonight hey Amy save some for the
rest of us you make a talented piece of
dog crap take your lives
and then of course there's Jeff Bridges
right mister I did get the feeling that
Jeff Bridges might have been on under
the influence of something like I hate
the faces all the actors are make you
and they go to it like me right bridges
that no he'd be too with his dumb
monologue why I didn't mind Jeff Bridges
he just kind of rambling about writing
the [ __ ] that's but that's what I'm
saying it's this idea that these people
are like you especially you know
important I'd love to hear his take like
we can do it like we can all we can
change things if we want to but like
they're these unique like special people
oh my god right so psychotic in our
system it's true we'll go back to it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Lorne Michaels can't really think that
this is funny he's probably doing it
probably proud of Andy Samberg he's one
of his guys but he can't really be
sitting there going like oh yeah I got
to do a bit like this on SNL maybe is
maybe maybe at this point he is no no
there's a lot more Black Panther is
nominated tonight for Best Picture Drama
it is the third highest-grossing movie
of all time in the u.s. movies the
characters ride around and rhinoceroses
like our horses I have been saying that
for years Hollywood she really she slept
over that one didn't you
yep right in rhinoceros [ __ ] butcher
that joke it's still funny to watch
someone trip
they ride in you ride on her right
laughter you wouldn't right insider
right now he certainly wouldn't now hey
get out of me was Black Panther better
than Bohemian Rhapsody I'm sure it was
yes I didn't see it yes Black Panther
was better I mean I Black Panther was
good but it it was a superhero movie it
was like a good superhero movie it
wasn't it didn't I don't I don't think
it did anything I've never seen a good
superhero movie in all my life I haven't
seen very light you know like Marvel
movies I hate them I hate DC and Marvel
I hate it all I don't love but what
about the Batman on culture what about
the Christian Bale Batman movies those
are good I saw one of them was okay okay
was it great all right you mean a bit of
a curmudgeon yeah and was the was the
Black Panther movie who were the
villains in that just other people over
there in the continent in Wakanda yeah
know who the villains just absorb Black
has two other villains I guess the
villains came from outside of Wakanda
but they did what they the villain is an
african-american actor yes yes it was it
was it was di knew where you were going
yeah know that you thought the white man
was being victimized right the hero of
Wakanda wanted to share the wealth that
Wakanda had with the world whereas the
villain of Wakanda wanted to keep what
was in Wakanda wakanda's right so but
both both were both right by African
American of legitimate arguments by the
way it's actually great take you know
keeping the wealth in the places you
know to mean well you know they say not
keeping the wealth in Africa's probably
led to the destruction of the continent
it's not Africa it's Wakanda what kind
of what kind of forever not keeping me
not keep them all then probably helped
destroy the
well they say that every great villain
might has to believe that they are not a
villain yeah you know you have to be
able to go yeah I could see where they
said why they still away if you've got
to secretly go I kind of sided with the
villain you know why are you saying that
you don't think comedy is doing well
when you watch this this really I'm so
happy because this is where this is
exactly what Hollywood is wanted this is
what they deserve yeah humorless comedy
when I was fake his stuff 1953 they did
a jokes at war they said this great that
they don't want to do away with comedy
they could do away with humor yeah so
they're fine doing humorless comedy
right right right comedies good yeah the
humor part we don't like what it's all
led to is this monologue yeah yeah well
let's have some oh I'm enjoying it great
well know who's here rolling here comes
rolling with a spot of tea knowledge win
that's nice it's very nice it's nice I -
honey you know me wrong I have a very
good relationship in many ways do you
take your tea bag out to text we have a
few laughs no it's been in for a long
time I can see just by looking thanks
Roland why don't leave it in when you
drink your tea I always get I always
leave my tea bag in well you're used to
like Roland walking in silently in
giving the tea and then leaving he's the
most hostile it would be worth it would
be better if he came in cursed us all
out and left oh yes it is it's a man
that's I'm telling you he's a please
pulling the puppet strings he's like
goddamn Citizen Kane right like Foster
Kane like I have no regard for
whatever's going on in this room whether
you're doing a show but I have no regard
for I just dropped me off because I
decided it's time right I'm big picture
and I'm and he's also kind of digging
that you guys let you know like this is
how it's done which that I agree with
you a spot readies literally never
brought a beverage inferred and myself
or Jim
well because yeah I mean that's you guys
have a long all much deeper relationship
with Roland then all of a half and thank
God man but I just feel like rug
first of all no shows except for the
only show is when Kelly Regis and Kelly
were together then you go there they
give you breakfast treats fun time no
show I've ever been on in this big
metropolitan city of New York ever has
fun breakfast treats the morning shows
it's really a business turn no they have
nothing after they have catered food
every catered breakfast there I'm having
been Anson said the new thing I guess
maybe but they didn't advocated
breakfast didn't nothing that's just the
legend they're just rumors they
circulate the whole you know there's a
bouncy castle back there behind those
doors it's amazing breakfast for guests
no at least now when I was there maybe
certain guests ooh yeah a listers you're
an a-lister to us Colin but that really
says more about us than it does all
right let's go back to this yeah I mean
they're not done with the monologue yet
this is great stand you like to joke I
love him right good-natured
right first of all one last thing yeah I
don't like that Roland gives you me this
much honey this is like one sliver of
honey he's got a small little container
that you would put a side of guacamole
the honey and he looked he literally
looked like a little baby bear it's less
than a quarter is about an eighth full
of honey it really does look like a
little pause but dipped in there do you
eat honey look who's been sleeping in my
bed now I don't usually eat it but I
appreciated the effort to gesture it's a
natural sweetener Roland is one of the
guys you just like because you know he's
not he doesn't play games you know I
mean he's you know he does like a lot of
jobs around here that we don't know
about rolling literally plays games
yes he does no it does not do other jobs
you don't know about he is a gossiping
political monster yes Roland ahead bones
of Roland's of [ __ ] public
backstabbing him he does nothing but
like South American like socialist like
minor officials yeah just suddenly he's
on top for a couple of years it doesn't
last that long you just [ __ ] take
some old now because nobody realized
that he allowed the coup to happen right
which would put him in a position right
yeah Pinochet says they killed a lot of
bad people
good people never got yeah yeah I guess
a that you know what enough of this talk
is too serious it's hilarious you gotta
get back to the lab there's a comedy
show we want to get and it's a comedy
show for today's audience Colin we don't
wanna live we're trying to get a younger
demo
exactly exactly let's hear some more
Troy ok
it was another huge year for director
Ryan Coogler a fellow Bay Area native
watch watch the look he gets watch the
thousand-yard which you don't watch do
you hear that audience that's like I
don't know if we can laugh it yes I
don't know like that that that line is
there's a little chip yeah yeah not even
the joke this setup was like oh I don't
like where this is going
yeah members of the actual Black Panther
Party saying like an audition just
kidding they were all framed and
murdered for wanting justice inequality
the world isn't always happen yeah his
face his face is just looking at him
like the [ __ ] do you know about the
Black Panthers where are you going guys
where you going the Sanford
where are you going with this do not
have a fake amused look on his face no
so you know this [ __ ] that I've had to
deal with in this industry to even get
this movie made where you going with
this Samberg where you going
we didn't need the politically correct
yeah exactly but go on but you you you
really are in a mood over this college
you didn't like Sam's little uh racism
like sibs cold cries for justice in the
middle of this crash a monologue know
you don't want comment maybe you need to
realize that you're able to trash this
monologue from a place of white
privilege that other people are not able
to trash it from okay once you can get
there I do not go for speak on this yeah
time to listen you do not get to speak
on this Colin what is that from it's
just like I think it's your answer
because the question is asinine oh I've
heard that started on Instagram you know
you put the clamp emojis okay make sense
thank you yes you did answer me you
didn't want to ask me but you did yes
but that is you didn't deserve an answer
I know I meant well now that I know now
I don't know why you're right but even
that is telling like it started the way
teenage girls talk yes and now it's like
appropriate for adults to like try to
make a political point yeah
you know well I mean that's you don't
get to talk on this yeah speak on this
but then I want to talk on this term
that's how I speak I say just coming
from his feelings right now doing my
thing can we go back just a little bit
cuz I want to hear Andy Samberg cuz as
we're watching Ryan Coogler face you
also have to hear like Andy samberg's
like he's just cramming in like just an
apology for the white race for
everything that happened to the black
dancers like you know the Black Panthers
yeah did some good did some bad yeah
yeah but Andy it's just like s Ryan
Coogler it's just staring holes into him
yeah these apologize yes chemistry is
good though it's good well you always
know before you go into a Golden Globes
you always know you're in for a treat
when they have an actress as the host
instead of a comedian
yeah you're like this is gonna be a
memorable one this is gonna be a good
one
yeah I want her take when are they gonna
stop having them I guess you have to
read off cue cards but it just never
works when they're going back in for
um yeah no never worse because the
chemistry is not real it never works no
maybe they need more hours of rehearsal
Jim ever think of that
no no no I think that's what it is
that's a great that's a great point
there's the thing about chemistry it can
be rehearsed yeah yeah just what just
rehearse it yeah do you think he rushes
through the good part of this I love it
listen to him rush through cuz he's easy
yes he's nervous about this one
yeah he's tap dancing excuse the
expression for this Thank You Colin you
do not get to speak on tap dance Panther
that starts off in Oakland this is not
what I would have imagined Ryan were
there like a bunch of old members of the
actual Black Panther Party saying just
kidding they were all framed and
murdered for wanting justice and
equality in the world isn't always has
been a nightmare it just seems worse now
because of our phones what else happened
this year and then everybody's
comfortable like did you hear people
wouldn't laugh when he said the Black
Panthers couldn't get an audition yeah
and then people like whoa I don't know
about all that the word black isn't it
we don't know what to do and then when
he says well the world's always been a
nightmare bad we're bad we're bad oh all
the Whitey's were just like we approve
let's go sign off on this continue
Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
[Applause]
and their performances were incredible
and he just proves and I'm just coming
up with this now that there can be a
hundred people in the room and 99 don't
believe in you and you just need one to
believe in you that's what he said to
heart
I figured that out stupid it was a meme
lady Lady Gaga said it in all of her
interviews in other news and Madonna
called her out because what Madonna said
that she copied that quote from her like
she copied all her songs
oh yeah I mean there's several layers
deep Lady Gaga's sexy yeah I think so
too actually
yeah anyway by the way it has the HOS
nice shoulders I don't like that dress
[Laughter]
it's just downstairs Wow has the host
given up on the well these have but have
the hosts of the Golden Globes given up
on the premise of the fake roasting
thing because now they're just
complimenting without pretending to
roast anymore oh I'll drink your tea
instead of Roland's just to piss him off
alright let's go for it I was just
thinking you know totally off-the-cuff
there could be a hundred people in the
room and 99 don't believe in you and you
just need one to believe in you and that
quite frankly was Bradley Cooper so true
so true yeah crazy meanwhile
what's-her-face Lady Gaga is the only
one I like is they interviewed before
uh-huh and she goes they go you like the
character in the movie character movies
gets taken out of nowhere and just
becomes a stalkers Bradley couple pushes
as she's nothing and she goes no that
was just the opposite she goes I was
like everybody get out of my way she
that's elbowing she made it in business
like a little honesty was yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
it is the first studio film with an
Asian American lead since ghost in the
shell in Aloha oh boy but he explained
look explain those to Jim to this square
I'm guessing those from movies relations
wrong Colin those are movies that they
whitewashed with dance called Johansson
and Emma Stone is in the back and she
goes I'm sorry she did Aloha right that
was her lo hot and ghost in the shell'
yeah Emma didn't do both of them didn't
know but I mean she yelled I'm sorry
from the back of the room right well it
wasn't there I guess otherwise who would
have expected one from hers yeah she was
out with chip Collins eating his entire
eggs in one pipe this monologue shippin
cringe yeah do you think so
uh-huh Wow right Jim crazy region chip
has better jokes on his mouth let's go I
don't know about that let's see I bet
it's gonna have real tight I'll bet it's
gonna end strong TV changes made over
200 million dollars at the box office
said Asian moms everywhere
she makes like a disapproving face
because you know Asian parents are
historically very hard to impress Tiger
moms that's right but you know that's a
joke for Sandra Oh to make not the rest
of of course you know I think if it's if
Sandra says it's okay to laugh we'll
laugh but beyond that I don't I don't
feel terribly comfortable I agree you
know and also to generalize like that is
not my cup of tea
no me neither right I don't so this this
joke rubbed me the wrong how's it going
though you like that know what she did
no pun intended rub me the wrong way
okay Colin you're really stepping over
the line with that one yeah jobs on the
line Colin Quinn makes Asian masseuse
joke whoa all right let's go back to it
[Applause]
hey she didn't seem so impressed so
cheers to crazy adjacent you guys
deserve a drink before we start getting
sloppy
Oh take care of my people so they don't
get the Asian flush gasps all around a
pepcid ac right there hey pause Jim
you're loving this aren't you
right the guy walks in with pepcid ac
and it's written in big letters with a
giant jar of pepcid ac and
camera-friendly letters well guess what
that when he can't blame their directors
like what's his purpose IG make sure the
perhaps it is big at the lab oh hey but
it's not the most sophisticated scroll
back just a little bit Cassandra Oh kind
of explained by the way my favorite part
you guys could even see that as the
director Colin has I'm holding a
cigarette here's to crazier changes you
guys deserve a drink before we start
getting sloppy I gotta take care of my
people so they don't get the Asian flush
now so around a pepcid ac right there
wait a minute wait what's the Asian
flush don't worry this job jokes not for
you copy that but I will say if we've
got a bunch of they're not even did you
notice she tripped on it yep she's
tripping on a lot of chunks isn't she
poor Sandra I don't might even gonna say
imagine doing it the other way I'm not
even comment but by the way the table of
Asia people they weren't laughing you
know they weren't like ah finally
somebody brought up the Asian flush they
were like what is this
yesterday see ya over there you know
it's the greatest Alan Ark yeah it's
just sitting there going this is not
funny I don't even pretend to be a made
a joke about the old is because they're
old right the old guy Alan Arkin doesn't
want any part of this shivay Schoen no I
didn't stunk did Christian always a bad
huh yeah Christian Bale was amazing did
he win anything I know he won Best Actor
okay in a comedy or musical or whatever
they say how's that comedy or musical
it's done in a comedic fashion okay it's
not like a straight-up comedy but it's
certainly you know I'm gonna say this
Christian Bale I think he's great at a
lot of his movies whoa hot thing do we
have the sizzle sound effect cause Colin
just dropped some flame wait wait wait
whoa yeah he's really good he plays a
lot of different characters too yes he
does that's he is amazing his chaining
very amazing go back to it Troy the boys
have invaded the wrong category based on
false intelligence
you know man you remember from the early
2000s Jim Iraq yeah never been there you
know go ahead Andy throughout the entire
film can you imagine how hard that must
have been I mean first of all you have
to get the family's permission to exhume
the body I don't even know where you
would begin with that conversation first
oh they were explaining to him that's my
favorite thing on awards when the person
pretends to be stupid yeah
because they didn't you know they didn't
want to actually make fun of Freddie
Mercury's teeth because Brian May might
have been offended by that
yeah you know Brian May is just sitting
out there he's like you better not make
a [ __ ] teeth joke right now well
they're the ones that ruined that movie
I was reading Oh Brian May Brian May and
uh what stay because they just wanted to
be about the band and not bring up the
Freddy's you know which gay and the AIDS
thing too much I mean they brought it in
but the movie is very kind it's a very
nice movie to everybody involved is the
best kind of movie you like that I do
that would be fine if they made it good
I could see that just wasting that song
at the beginning I had to turn it off
right what was the song this is somebody
to love yeah I think so I mean I told my
the best songs and they're just it's
over him marching around it's really
green growing up nobody liked I liked
Queen you know
I told Jim they reenacted the entire
live aid set at the end of the movie
what they did like the full 20 minutes
that's all that piece of bagel corny
well you don't want this bagel it's a
delicious poppy seed delight get eggs
yeah it's when a little piece yeah take
a little chunk you guys are such great
friends I love having it we go way back
yeah you're like Alan Arkin and Michael
Douglas just the two of you wacky
adventures come kick Minsky whatever all
right let's go back to it
first man is also house studios look for
directors first man available then pair
of man then team of man then eventually
maybe woman right on somebody had to say
it Lady Gaga she's like whoa
apparently she doesn't get out much no
she's a no I've never heard that what is
it 1995 I mean I got idiot
people hate every day it's commonplace
is that edgy I have to believe that some
of the people laughing at this joke
our laughing at it as in like I can't
believe this is happening but the
laughing at the joke dollars no you know
hey so go away why a lot of money and a
good looking they're dumb Colin you make
you crazy you make a really bad nose
bully they're dumb
yes just a bunch of stupid people
people laughing it's lines yeah yeah
because you have no choice they that you
have to put yourself into a spare
brainwashed state in certain
totalitarian societies right you go okay
if I'm gonna survive here I better start
thinking this way and living this way
yeah in order to survive in Hollywood
you just have to submit to the to the
way the the thinking to the will of
Allah
that's right using expressions away
sorry mom let me hear yes very good that
was that let me get a little rant again
I was important directors right on first
man if no man available then pair of man
then team of man then eventually maybe
woman
hold on Travis what are you gonna say
you look uncomfortable it goes on for so
long with the same voice
yeah well mainly mainly studios are run
by cavemen bad men man woman man she's
doing Tim Allen in the 90s the thing the
punchline was not clear when she first
said that's how Studios also look for
direct no right it needed yeah
it needed a funny voice and a nice long
exposure pair of man you know what a man
wasn't available why would a pair of men
be available and maybe woman yeah okay
yeah a pair of men you know what the
Coen brothers should have stood up and
said what are you just saying a pair of
men with the Coen brothers somebody do
the [ __ ] work we did shut up yeah
wouldn't that be great they stood up
what the [ __ ] did you just say you seen
No Country for Old Men yeah you know the
marvelous mrs. nasal is nominated again
for multiple award
it's the show that makes audiences sit
up and say wait is this anti-semitic
you ever see the marvelous mrs. Mazal no
no you nerds how was it ah it's like
anything else it's like it looks good
and you're like you know the sets are
gray looks like the 50s kind of cool
idea but then the stand up is [ __ ]
there's not a [ __ ] funny line in a
show about calm and that's not just that
show everything I see what setup I'm
like it's all good
where's the [ __ ] jokes right where's
the good [ __ ] jokes man that's the
only value we [ __ ] have right
otherwise I don't want to watch anybody
and stand up living their life unless
you go you know what that person
whatever they are but you know what when
I'm stage I'm [ __ ] laughing what the
[ __ ] right like you watch them live this
shitty existence I mean they go on stage
and they're not that funny and you're
like what we do I get tortured they're
all tortured man right I'm [ __ ] want
to get to my real self you know then
they get on stage and it's like their
real self is not funny so it's just it
defeats the entire idea of why we've
grabbed any value whatsoever yeah it's
just an embarrassment cause it's like no
no but I don't give a [ __ ]
tortured be fine but when you're on say
Jake that person's goddamn it has to be
fine to be their personal [ __ ] life
because it's an excuse to not be funny
like hey that person was real guess what
Mitch Hedberg he wasn't [ __ ] telling
you his real person life he was [ __ ]
hilarious right you know I mean whatever
it is it doesn't have to be one category
but it has to be funny Rock oh my god it
makes me mad
you don't like some of the just the the
drive storytelling of comedy because
guess what writing jokes is [ __ ] hard
so everybody you know fill in all the
[ __ ] around
but then on stage time you like oh see
that's why it's [ __ ] hard come it
can't be funny you know what can
sometimes comedians have a
responsibility to just speak truth to
power you know that is true don't punch
down but if it's not now sometimes truth
to power is more important absolutely
punching up is always more important to
me yeah you don't punch down as a
philosophy right Jim I can't
[Laughter]
Darren Criss of Ruth's Chris Steakhouse
is here
his name's Darren Criss yeah [ __ ]
chip joke it really is [ __ ]
steakhouse yeah [ __ ] now you're
playing for kiss yeah I hate drama
you thinking of peanut up we know Peter
Criss I don't like that this [ __ ] in
the middle of a chip thing so I better
explain it to get the laugh you think
was it coming either way chip it was
chips explaining it
you think reached in there and said ship
you got explain this one chip I think I
think we'll get ahead of you change your
chips wrong chip is not an obsessed with
kiss Jim is the one who even with the
fans to be left you know high and dry
the other two middle-aged oh my kiss
[ __ ] just chip let him know who he is
I know you're talking about chip yeah
that would be great to see an actual
like a like an episode or like why
lights on with chip and Jim's like
directing chip right you actually go
like that Disney move you like the Pixar
movie where you go in the head that
Lewis Black was playing anger except
it's inside chips head and Jim is
controlling everything in the brain or
you can do altitude was like a psycho
like the movie psycho huh what Jim goes
up hey how you doing and he goes up and
starts yelling a chip and chips in there
good I think it could be - there's a lot
of potential yeah yeah Jim early is a
horror movie character when you think
about he's a [ __ ] murderer yeah it's
true
so is Jim yeah let's go back to it
Darren did you guys see Versace by the
way yeah I thought like half the series
I think yeah how could you stop watching
it it's funny it was this [ __ ]
was amazing I thought so too Jim you
would love this guy's before he was
great he played watch any goddamned this
[ __ ] thing's amazing he played the
killer he played Andrew Cunanan yeah
yeah it was unbelievable he was amazing
yeah amazing what this is a great [ __ ]
is he nominated or is that yeah I think
he was boy Lorillard he won yeah case
you had to show DVR'd for us
[Laughter]
Golden Gloves
it's [ __ ] gym you will [ __ ] love
this so a comedian shouldn't make
certain jokes cuz they're mean but he
wins an award for playing a guy who
murdered someone great well no I didn't
murder multiple people Oh
to be fair call just-just-just you're
gonna love this [ __ ] thing it's
amazing right right but you know I mean
but don't make fun of this he didn't
make light of it don't be mean he played
it in a serious waging right yeah
but nice play the guy who murdered a
bunch of him he didn't play he's played
it funny
who's funny yeah he's great he was great
way around show he's great I love that
most of that stuff what's his name who
does that who did Glee and his tuxedo
was asinine through the show creator
Ryan Murphy does a hell of a good job
making TV shows oh yeah he does well you
know with this tuxedo well it just bugs
me because it's trying to be funny and
in 1989 at the MTV Music Awards I tried
to be funny and more like wacky tuxedo
what you wear and I went out with this
girl
and she she was disgusted with me why
cuz she didn't want to go out with me
anyway you need to wear the funny tuxedo
outside of the award oh now you gotta go
out and she couldn't [ __ ] wait to get
rid of me
what was the tuxedo I forget her name um
when she went as your date she was my
date and she was just like I showed up
with the tuxedo I saw the face she was
like disgusting I just look like a real
[ __ ] [ __ ] but you give the [ __ ]
what's that no I didn't get to [ __ ] her
let's see that I probably wouldn't have
got to [ __ ] her but the tuxedo killed
kibosh any chance that's when comedy was
comedy though when a comedian would walk
in and be like you know what I may not
get to tell jokes tonight but my suits
gonna be hilarious it's funny because I
remember seeing Robin when he was in
like 1991 wearing suspenders like mime
suspenders right and I was like yeah man
we don't have to be dressed up the
comedian like you know I like these
comedians if I could now the earth you
know can I start business I used to like
fun outfits you know what was fun about
your tuxedo what was wacky about it um
it was just it was like this it was like
that only with yellow it was a floral
there's a yellow floral tuxedo yeah when
did you realize that it wasn't funny and
then it kind of stung when the girl's
face just looked disgusted when I came
to
all you went to pick her up with that
yeah we got to present me and Ken over
presented to Madonna the UH some award
and can tried to give her a kiss I
didn't at least I didn't try to kiss her
she was like disgusted by us from a game
show
we were like you know big in the MTV
world of course do we have that I would
love I love this maybe just do Colin
Quinn VMA yeah VMA put Madonna maybe in
there there might have been 1990 or 1988
it might have been 1988 it was really
early you know yeah wait no I don't see
I want to see your tuxedo yeah it's
pretty
unfortunately Colin Quinn's appearance
at the VMAs did not go down on MTV's top
100 no it's unfortunate that's really
that's too bad let's watch there was
another joke coming up though yeah you
look like a million bucks at the SNL
thing that wasn't that was a good tuxedo
yeah thank you yeah it's true I did look
all right let's go back to it but you
know enough with the fashion talk this
shows about the jokes you're right let's
get some laughs man yeah all righty then
yeah you're gonna like you remember this
bit calm your horse yeah you're gonna
like this is you know mind a bit popping
into a monologue dude you don't know I
prefer it okay good
and this bit the good thing about this
bit is it it's a 30-second bit that's
stretched into four minutes long one
yes a long
[Applause]
and I gotta say I knew Jim Carrey's
paintings but I had no idea he had done
acting he was really good although I am
seeing that Jim Carrey sitting up front
tonight in the movie section even though
he's nominated for a TV show oh yeah
that's not gonna work I'm so sorry Jim
but we're gonna have to ask you to
vacate the movie section and go sit with
the TV folk you're kidding right
you know what city much married it's
very lucky is that you know yeah you're
right Jim that he was miked okay
somebody saying when I say the TV folk I
don't like the fact that people use folk
ironically now write another little
[ __ ] thing in comedy the folk it also
I blame it all on [ __ ] David
Letterman I'm telling you let him in as
funny as he was he also brought this
folksy irony to comedy that just [ __ ]
makes me sick moans you don't like it no
I hate it
do you like when people call each other
sir as like kind of like they're not
actually meaning it respectfully there's
just like I don't know about that sir um
I don't know because we do that in
comedy it's such a natural thing we like
you sir yeah I mean that's kind of
annoying yeah I can't help myself I
still do it I mean it's like I say hey
guy hey miss yeah you have to say what
you do say miss that's a bad thing we
say missus yes what I'm saying that hey
miss or man yeah but so I know I think I
know what you're saying yeah I don't
really mean hey sir I mean like the
people at bow yes sir that whole [ __ ]
org well no sir
or like it'll pop up in like when people
are kind of having conversations with
each other like friends are having
conversation for the throw serves in
Kevin Smith does that but he's been
doing that that's how he's kept watch
for his whole life
this is why bothers me Kevin Smith was
the first person that I noticed doing it
and I was like I don't mind when Kevin
Smith because him but then all the
disciples and all the fans of Kevin
Smith yeah starting to pick up on that
yes a good point sir but that like well
played yeah oh wow it's really good well
played kaolin well played two shades
another favor well played sir Touche
Touche what's he talking about I like to
shake hold on I want to say something
bad this this this discussion today is
expose something you're a square I
happen to like to share you're out of
the loop are you
starting to get annoyed at Jim Norton's
irrelevant talk about one thing - Shay's
not part of that yes it is it's people
who use those stupid expressions well
played
yes he said well played - Shay you here
- Shay in your day to day no but I've
heard you stand by that yes I do I think
Colin is being a bit of a bully that's
exactly what I would say if somebody
said lying - shakily but you know I mean
I I don't know but either way it's that
whole school of like oh yes I mean Smith
probably did [ __ ] started but I
didn't actually but yeah Kevin Smith
wasn't doing it so he copied Letterman
and David Letterman the same I love
David Letterman I love Kevin Smith I
like David but you guys are only like
that's basically huh just because you
like them and they started and they were
organic and it's their thing right
doesn't mean we should forgive them it's
like saying hey the first the [ __ ]
Montreal flight attendant well you know
he liked to have unprotected sex in 1978
mr. Ground Zero Touche all right let's
try to get through this this model was
good I can't believe I liked it more
than I thought can't believe but we're
going through the whole thing I can't
believe it
but you're on kidding and that's on TV
so yeah even then they have to say
you're our hero they can't [ __ ]
commit to the baby [ __ ] it's it's
positivity man right great for comedy
positivity and comedy go together well
it's good stuff makes people feel better
I just finished the film
it's called Sonic the Hedgehog comes out
in November Wow well you know come back
next year I'm sure we'll be nominated
all right I'm going should I take my
dinner too I wouldn't want to leave any
of my DNA in the film section I see your
lips moving but there's a delay see how
long as good as Jin long it's long I was
hoping for more there is one JEP good
good yeah they're not they're not they
haven't really driven in a hole by the
way now that they've done the nice thing
of pointing out that the really
important people sit up front as soon as
the monologue was over of course Jim
Carrey was right back to the front
meanwhile poor Lucy hi poor Lucy Liu is
on camera in the second section going
like what the [ __ ] why would you bring
up that all the important people are up
front and then show me and it's a joke
from a different time TV is bigger than
fascinating yes of course it is he's
putting up two glasses on his eyeballs
like their glasses isn't fair like um
binoculars right likes yeah
it's good he's a physical guy you saw
some props he decided to go for it yeah
you know yes
decided to go for it there's just he
said there's still some juice left in
this Barry
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
now I I know we're up here joking but on
a serious note good this year we saw
black panther crazy rich Asians feel
street could talk okay we're starting to
we're starting to skirt into the area
that we've already heard earlier on in
the show do you want to go all the way I
do you do it so you wanted stuff you
wanting here Sandra Oh's heartfelt
speech again oh my god yeah
did you hear Jim I did even though you
didn't watch this no I played him just
one little clip it was until you got
here that we decided it was necessary to
play the entire goddamn opening
monologue for an hour again now does
does rollin ever come in and just go
like hey guys you know like just pick it
up like get rid of this model move on to
something right he'll come in and say
like a Colin came in to promote
something I don't think he wants to sit
here for an hour watching the Globes
from well he's right in that you guys
are very rude to not promote me but I
this is much more important I agree I
haven't been invited to assure you
neither have I to tell you the truth I
got invited to Mike Birbiglia show Nach
I did show my text at me invited me yeah
you guys we invited the opening night if
you want to go to stupid opening lines
opening night two weeks you would I we
would have gotten invited doing reviews
now that's not true we haven't invited
anyone to opening night yes all right I
got me an invitation should be a big
event I'd like to go I'd like to go
around the corner from the cellar
yeah at Minetta perfect location sure is
it seems like the place to see and be
seen so so yeah I'm so happy to be
around they're going to the cellar you
like yours better than the cherry lane I
love it the best of its but my dream was
always to just work as close to the
cellar as possible but look we can get
to sell it's all it's all family life we
can't get too deep into promoting
Colin's new project because we're not
down with the monologue yet but we
haven't even said it so don't even worry
about it okay yeah it was around the
corner from the cellar let's go all
right let's continue on with the
monologue I'm at the Blue Note
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they're not just here tonight because
they resonated with audiences Hollywood
often ignores they're here because they
told stories that resonated with
everyone and that is truly a beautiful
thing
Wow Andy can I just say that you just
read all of my lines off the
teleprompter you know you could tell
it's real because in real life she would
have said off the teleprompter she
wouldn't have just said you just read
all my lines yeah it's important that
she would have made sure that if you
read all her line she did inform the
audience that a teleprompter the writing
that we use here the writing is good
it's it's solid oh my god I just totally
whitewashed your speech that's good
right oh my god what just the joke was
it's an amazing learning experience yeah
yeah you know yeah I always said why
have fun with it you know yeah yeah this
is this is the space just what I just
want to know as long as they understand
yeah as long as they're not shocked
right when you know Bob the tool and die
maker from southwest Missouri isn't
rushing out to see the latest projects
when they do this kind of stuff right
whitewashing yeah I was I got turpentine
he's trying to scrub the [ __ ] white
paint off his goddamn hands right now
right working 80 hours and they going
whitewashing that's not how it happens
but what a learning experience right
sorry two different ideas of society I
had never felt like it was so out of
touch as it was last night like it's
like the guys are both wrong the left
for me personally the level of out of
touch nests that Hollywood has decided
to double did - yeah they're doubling
down they're strengthening the bubble
that they all live in instead for a
second for a second they were like maybe
let's explore what's outside and they're
like no no we don't like that out there
we don't like they're they're all
calling us out as pedophiles and whatnot
let's strengthen the bubble let's say
that we're saving you from pedophiles
not we are the pedophiles yeah and let's
make it let's make it a double thick
yeah exactly and that's why it's doubly
disappointing that you thought the Jeff
Bridges monologue was just some
character that he played in
you know in the Coen Brothers movie
instead of just part of that a stoned
version of this idiocy what the dude was
just stoned you know like oh the dude is
giving a speech that movie bugs me to
watch it I can't help that movie I love
the Coen brothers and that you know Big
Lebowski Mouse it was okay exactly
had some funny scenes John Turturro was
amazing but it was like I shouldn't be
putting the biblical standards that it
is should be it should be number like 11
of Coen Brothers movies what's your
favorite Coen Brothers movie
no let's coursing okay Fargo it deserves
the yeah it's Barton Fink okay
I don't think I can understand hating it
but when you lived it when you spend any
time in LA you're like oh god that's
exactly what I was going through there
okay okay starting to be boring let's
pick it up list them all or we could go
back to this yeah yes stage tonight
because because I wanted to be here to
look out into this audience and witness
this moment of change and I'm not
pulling myself I'm not fooling myself
next year could be different it probably
will be yeah next year what the white
man is gonna clamp down next year eyelet
Aryan the white man is coming
this moment is real trust me it is real
because I see you
like that one moment that laugh whoever
did that laugh I want to see every movie
they ever do we I want to support
whoever left we had 11 minutes of awful
and that one moment which is one person
in that audience acknowledging what that
last 11 minutes was and look at the look
ready she can't believe someone just
laughed at her dumb actor moment yeah
exactly right because it's just that her
actor teary eyes I'm looking at you kiss
she's portraying emotion
she's not feeling portraying emotion
emotion right now this moment is real
trust me it is real because I see the
greatest thing you've ever seen in your
life that laughs this is so beautiful
and [ __ ] and offensive to her so
offensive she was sitting there going
okay this is my moment this whole ten
minutes of lunacy is gonna always gonna
all culminate in my moment this will be
the moment tomorrow everybody's gonna
say Sandra Oh speaks for the people that
don't have a voice except for one person
that goes yeah I want to know who or is
it left and so and I want to know what
the person next to how they hard they
nudge serious whoever whoever was
laughing given the Cecil B DeMille
Lifetime Achievement Award next year
kids what a great laugh yes have you did
more to Hollywood than anyone ever could
all these phases of change and now so
will everyone else what
and you see this where they're painting
to all the women of color in the own ass
yeah that's a girl from Roma wow that
was great actually I was really good
that was really really meaningful yeah
that's how the show started and I said
I'm sitting there out of some feeling of
having to do this out of some feeling of
obligation yes I'm gonna sit here for
that it went three and a half hours I'm
gonna stay here until 11:30 tonight and
I'm gonna watch this whole goddamn show
yeah well you were right yeah it was
anyway it's it's a cultural benchmark
yeah yeah